how many times have you been in love and
what made him special I was 21 and he
was 39 and he was in an open
relationship with his wife and I think
this kind of started me on my journey of
unconventional relationships nor an open
relationship with his wife okay he took
me to La for our second date she knew
and everything yeah yeah yeah and what I
loved about him was his confidence true
confidence and true security like at
that time I was a stripper and he if
anything enjoyed the fact that prer got
to see me but he got to enjoy me and he
had he was so secure in himself and in
his relationship he was a great opening
to show what a true confidence of a man
was